[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Marietta Slomka guten
Abend wie schlecht dieser Krieg derzeit
für Wladimir Putin läuft zeigt sich auch
darin dass er heute für seine Truppen in
der Ukraine einen neuen Kommandeur
berief mitten im Strom die Pferde zu
wechseln da scheint die Not groß zu sein
der Tag begann für ihn aber auch schon
denkbar schlecht vom kurz nach 6 Uhr in
der Früh stand seine krimbrücke in
Flammen wie die Explosion ausgelöst
wurde ist noch ungeklärt die meisten
Beobachter gehen davon aus dass das ein
sorgfältig geplanter Schlag der Ukrainer
war eine militärische spezialoperation
sozusagen Darlehen
Aufnahmen einer Überwachungskamera es
ist Samstagmorgen auf der Brücke
zwischen der annektierten Krim und dem
russischen Festland schiebt sich
schwarzer Rauch über den Morgenhimmel
die russischen Behörden vermelden drei
Tote
nach vorläufigen Informationen wurde
heute morgen auf dem Autobahnabschnitt
der krimbrücke von der Seite der
halbinseltermann aus ein Lastwagen in
die Luft gesprengt sieben Kraftstofftank
seines in Richtung der Halbinsel Krim
fahrenden Zuges gerieten dabei in Brand
die Fahrbahn stürzte an Zweigstellen ein
die krimbrücke sie ist eines der
wichtigsten Prestigeprojekte des Kremls
von Putin 2018 höchstpersönlich eröffnet
19 Kilometer lang ein zementierter
Anspruch Russlands auf die
völkerrechtswidrig annektierte Halbinsel
Krim bestehend aus einer
Eisenbahnverbindung und einer
vierspurigen Autobahn und sie ist ein
wichtiges Nadelöhr über sie laufen große
Teile der militärischen Versorgung der
Krim und der Front im Süden des Landes
immer wieder hatte Russland betont dass
ein Angriff auf die Brücke ein klares
Überschreiten der roten Linie sei wir
können davon ausgehen dass Russland
reagieren wird aber wie diese Reaktion
aussehen wird ob das ein Angriff auf
zivile Infrastruktur also die
Lebensgrundlagen der Ukraine sein wird
ob das ein der Versuch einer
militärischen Reaktion sein wird
wahrscheinlich müssen wir mit einem
einem Mix aus all diesen rechnen aus
Kiew selbst heute klare Worte vom
präsidentenberater Krim die Brücke der
Anfang alles illegale muss zerstört
werden alles gestohlene muss an die
Ukraine zurück alles von Russland
besetzte vertrieben werden was er nicht
sagt ob die Ukraine hinter der Explosion
steckt in der Vergangenheit hatte Kiew
immer wieder angekündigt sich die Krim
zurückzuholen und die brückenanlagen zu
beschießen sobald es die vom Westen
gelieferten schweren Waffen dafür gebe
in Kiew selbst ist die beschädigte
Brücke bereits verewigt und beliebtes
Fotomotiv denn egal ob Unfall oder
Anschlag für sie hat Russlands
Kampfmoral und Logistik mit dem Tag
heute einen erneuten Rückschlag erlitten
Sabotage an kritischer Infrastruktur gab
es heute Vormittag in Deutschland auch
wenn natürlich nicht vergleichbar wer
den Zugverkehr im Norden über
stundenlang liegt es noch unklar eines
ist dadurch aber auf jeden Fall deutlich
geworden wie verletzlich Verkehrswege
und andere Netze sind Henna Hebestreit
berichtet
kein Zug brachte sie am Morgen nach
irgendwo auch für viele Fahrgäste am
Hamburger Hauptbahnhof begann der
Reisetag in langen Schlangen vor den
informationsschaltern für drei Stunden
hatte die Bahn alle Signale auf halt
gestellt weil es auf den Strecken keine
Kommunikation zwischen Lokführer und
fahrdienstleistern mehr gab für
Eisenbahner und Reisende hieß es erstmal
kein Anschluss ja die Lage ist ernst
würde ich sagen also wir warten schon
sehr lange wir werden nach München
gefahren ist alles ausgebucht wir wissen
nicht wie wir jetzt wegkommen was mit
unseren Tickets ist wir wollen ja im ICE
jetzt nach Dortmund der fährt ja jetzt
leider nicht und da wollten wir uns
heute Dortmund gegen Bayern uns heute
angucken deswegen
während sich die Gestrandeten um ihr
Fortkommen kümmerten wurde bald deutlich
es war keine technische Panne die die
Bahnreisenden am Reisen hinderte der
Bundesverkehrsminister mit ersten
Ergebnissen handelt sich hier eindeutig
um vorsätzliche und gezielte
sabotagehandlungen über die Hintergründe
kann man heute nur spekulieren die
Bundespolizei hat die Ermittlungen
aufgenommen unbekannte hatten in Berlin
Hohenschönhausen und im
nordrhein-westfälischen Herne am frühen
Morgen gleich zwei unabhängige
Kommunikationssysteme der Bahn
zerschnitten die Täter verfügten
offenbar über große Fach- und
Ortskenntnis die Anschläge lösten bei
der Bahn eine Kette von Maßnahmen aus
wir haben für solche Fälle natürlich
Sicherungsmechanismen die auch perfekt
funktioniert haben die Bahn hat sofort
den Zugverkehr eingestellt und das
Krisenmanagement der Bahn hat so gut
funktioniert dass in Abstimmung mit
meinem Ministerium noch am Vormittag der
Zugverkehr wieder aufgenommen werden
konnte die Folgen des mehrstündigen
Stillstands im norddeutschen Bahnnetz
haben sich freilich noch lange durch den
Tag gezogen obwohl die Techniker der
Bahn innerhalb weniger Stunden die
zerstörten Leitungen Flicken konnten wer
mit welchen Motiven den Zugverkehr
durcheinander brachte das zu klären ist
jetzt Aufgabe der Ermittler
morgen könnte die Zeit der großen
Koalition in Deutschland vorerst Enden
Niedersachsen ist das letzte Bundesland
in dem SPD und CDU noch gemeinsam
regieren nach den letzten Umfragen vor
der Wahl sieht es dort aber eher nach
Veränderung aus Rot-Grün oder eine
Dreierkonstellation so oder so ist es
eine Landtagswahl in Krisenzeiten die in
Berlin auch als der berühmte
Stimmungstest gewertet wird denn gleich
manche das am Wahlabend dann
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so gern hören
wollen
Iller und Fabian Köhler haben den
letzten Wahlkampftag beobachtet
gut gesichert der Wahlkampfabschluss der
SPD in Hannovers Altstadt Kanzler Scholz
ist gekommen mit weiterer
Bundesprominenz sie wollen ihn
unterstützen Stefan weil will zum
dritten Mal Ministerpräsident werden er
will durch diese Krisenzeiten führen
doch längst nicht alle fühlen sich
unterstützt von der Politik nur einen
Häuserblock weiter ziehen mehr als 3000
Querdenker am nieder deutschen Landtag
vorbei die Pfiffe schallen bis auf die
Bühne
ich finde das ist ein Moment in dem man
als Land zusammenstehen muss in dem es
darum geht dass wir unsere Kraft die wir
haben unsere Solidarität zu der befähig
sind nutzen um eine so schwierige
Situation auch zu bestehen bei der Wahl
in Niedersachsen spielt die
Landespolitik kaum eine Rolle die
Energiekrise das bestimmende Thema weil
liegt in Umfragen vor der CDU gibt sich
im Wahlkampf staatsmännisch gelassen das
Land bei ihm in guten Händen so der
wahlkampfslogan doch dem Protest einiger
die Störaktionen bei Auftritten bekam er
immer wieder zu spüren ich habe noch
keinen Wahlkampf erlebt wo in den
Gesichtern der Bürgerinnen und Bürger so
viele Fragezeichen standen wo so viele
Sorgen zum Ausdruck gebracht worden sind
und für gibt es ja leider auch Gründe
also die Stimmung war schon eine ganz
besondere und umso dankbare bin ich
dafür dass gerade in den letzten Tagen
der Zuspruch immer spürbarer wird die
CDU macht die Wahl zu einer Abstimmung
über die Krisenpolitik der
Ampelkoalition im Bund im endspur des
Wahlkampfes will Parteichef Friedrich
Merz Band Althusmann zum Erfolg
verhelfen es ist sein zweiter Anlauf und
der versucht die CDU in Niedersachsen an
die Macht zurückzubringen
ich sage sehr klar Herr weil es Teil der
Ampel er stützt sie und diesen Kurs
können wir so nicht unterstützen wenn
Niedersachsen am Ende eine starke CDU
hat die eine Regierung stellen wird dann
ist das auch ein klares Signal in
Richtung Berlin ich denke das könnte
sogar das Ende der Ampel einleiten denn
das was wir im Moment erleben ist
chaotisch die CDU warnt vor einer
rot-grüne Neuauflage und sie treibt die
SPD mit der Forderung nach Kursänderung
in der akw-frage vor sich her was geht
in den Köpfen dieser Bundesregierung vor
die sichere Versorgung für 2 10
Millionen Haushalte mit drei
Kernkraftwerken in diesem Lande
ernsthaft den Frage zu stellen die CDU
will den Umschwung durch einen Sieg in
Niedersachsen doch gewinnt die SPD das
der nötige Rückenwind für eine Ampel in
schwierigen Zeiten
und jetzt geht es bei Dir weiter Hanna
bundesverteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
hat Litauen besucht um eine neue
deutsche kampftruppenbrigade in Dienst
zu stellen diese soll künftig die
nato-ostflanken Litauen verstärken der
Führungsstab wird dabei fest auf dem
NATO-Stützpunkt in ruklar stationiert
zudem besuchte Lambrecht die erste
Militärübung der Brigade mit litauischen
Truppen
250 Bundeswehrsoldaten sind dabei
beteiligt
in Berlin haben laut Polizei rund 10.000
Menschen gegen die Energiepolitik der
Bundesregierung demonstriert und folgten
damit einem Aufruf der AFD deren
Vorsitzender krupala forderte ein Ende
der Sanktionspolitik gegen Russland und
sprach sich gegen die gaspreisbremse aus
gleichzeitig fanden mehrere
Gegenkundgebungen statt nach Angaben der
Polizei waren fast 2000 Beamte im
Einsatz
im Nordwesten Irlands sind bei einer
Explosion an einer Tankstelle mindestens
zehn Menschen ums Leben gekommen
darunter zwei Jugendliche und ein Kind
acht Menschen wurden außerdem verletzt
laut Polizei deutet derzeit alles auf
ein tragisches Unglück als Ursache hin
man ermittelte aber in alle Richtungen
die Explosion am Freitagnachmittag
zerstörte neben der Tankstelle Teile
einer Wohnanlage
dass eine Staatsmacht die 16-jährigen
Mädchen den Schädel zertrümmert wenn sie
Aufbegehren was seine solche Staatsmacht
vor nichts zurückschreckt war klar es
ist insofern auf entsetzliche Weise auch
nicht überraschend dass das iranische
Regime auf protestierende Jugendliche
scharf schießen lässt und zahlreiche
Tote hinnimmt und trotzdem machen sie
weiter auch heute und immer wieder gehen
Frauen und junge Mädchen voran mit einer
Todesverachtung hinter der sehr viel Mut
und Verzweiflung stehen Lück valpot
berichtet
tausende waren es heute Mittag an dieser
Universität in Teheran ein paar Straßen
weiter steckten Demonstranten einen
Polizeiposten in Brand karac Shiraz
esfan in vielen Städten gingen Menschen
erneut auf die Straße zunehmend
entschlossen das Regime abzuschütteln
gestern Abend konnte es jeder lesen wir
haben keine Angst mehr vor euch wir
werden kämpfen stand da über Teherans
größter Stadtautobahn das Regime
antwortet mit bekannten Mitteln brutale
Gewalt Tritte Knüppel Schüsse im
kurdischen sanandac wurde ein Mann im
fahrenden Auto erschossen einer von mehr
als 130 Toten so Amnesty International
unter den Opfern diese sechs jungen
Frauen
zwei von ihnen die 16-jährige Nika und
die 17-jährige Sarina ihre Leichen
Wiesen schwere Kopfverletzungen auf
Erklärung der Behörden ein unglücklicher
Sturz aus großer Höhe und bei Sarina sie
habe sich das Leben genommen
Darstellungen auf die niemand mehr etwas
gibt und die immer mehr Iranerinnen und
Iraner auf die Barrikaden treibt
Demonstrationen sind seit drei Wochen
verboten werden gnadenlos
niedergeknüppelt ausgenommen das hier
propaganda-versammlungen des Regimes wir
am Mittwoch in Teheran ein verzweifelter
Versuch den entlarvenden Bildern von
blutiger Unterdrückung der eigenen
Bevölkerung etwas entgegenzusetzen
wenn die alles zerstören wenn die
Polizisten und bassivkräfte töten dann
werden Sie uns kennenlernen wir stehen
hinter der Regierung
Präsident rahissi zeigte sich heute an
der als Sacher Faun Universität in
Teheran mit den bekannten
Durchhalteparolen
unsere Feinde glauben sie könnten die
Unruhen in die Universitäten tragen aber
unsere Studenten und Professoren lassen
das nicht zu
draußen fordern Studentinnen derweil Tod
den foltern und gleich gegenüber
schwenken Regime Treue Fahnen auch
Ausländer geraten jetzt verstärkt ins
Visier der Behörden ein IMEI verhaftetes
französisches Touristenpaar wurde im
Staatsfernsehen mit einem offenbar
erzwungenen Geständnis als französische
Agenten vorgeführt Paris forderte die
sofortige Freilassung sprach empört von
staatlichen Geiseln alle Franzosen
wurden aufgefordert Iran umgehend zu
verlassen ihre Sicherheit sei doch nicht
mehr gewährleistet auch das Auswärtige
Amt in Berlin rät dringend von Reisen
nach Iran ab
zum Sport genauer zu einer echten
Überraschung beim Tischtennis wo das
deutsche Team bei der Mannschafts-WM in
China das Endspiel erreicht hat das
junge Team von Bundestrainer Rosskopf
konnte das Halbfinale gegen Südkorea
nach mehr als drei eineinhalb Stunden
für sich entscheiden und gewann mit drei
zu zwei Gegner der Deutschen im morgigen
Finale ist Gastgeber China
und jetzt die Lottozahlen die lauten 7 8
15 36 38 49 Superzahl 7 alle Angaben wie
immer ohne Gewähr
fehlt noch der Blick auf die
Wetteraussichten morgen nach
Nebelauflösung auf sonnig oder nur
locker bewölkt im Süden Lokal auch
länger trübe an den alten dichte Wolken
Höchstwerte 14 bis 19 Grad in den
nächsten Tagen eine Mischung aus Sonne
Wolken und Nebel am Montag im Nordwesten
und im Süden ein paar Schauer 14 bis 22
Grad
das war es im heute journal weitergeht
zum Aktuellen Sportstudio und wir
wünschen Ihnen noch einen angenehmen
Abend wir sehen tschüss
[Musik]